And season two was five episodes and they
just pulled the plug and so-
Good.
Yeah.
The people who loved it, me, probably only
me, they were like, "Just one girl in Philadelphia
is watching this.
Let's cancel the show."
Hi, I'm Brian.
I am here with Tom and Nina, and we are going
to talk about forgotten TV series that we
think should get a reboot.
Tom, what TV series that is forgotten do you
think should get a reboot?
If I had to pick one and I do, because you
asked me to...
That's the assignment.
Keeping in mind, I'm a nerd, right?
Yeah.
I'm aware.
I'm not adjusting well to life in the outside.
I would love to see more Farscape.
Specifically, I would love to see more Farscape
with the kind of budget that they used to
give to TV shows back when there weren't as
many TV shows.
You remember when you would turn on Deep Space
Nine, and it would just be...
I'm sorry.
This is instantly turning into an Andy Rooney
60 Minutes.
Remember back in the day, used to be able-
You use to be able to watch Deep Space Nine
and see-
You know what really grinds my gears?
True stories of aliens walking around and
a thing.
It was like the Mall of America, but it was
full of forehead ridges.
Yeah, I loved Farscape.
If you've never seen it, it was Jim Henson's
weird kid making his own Star Trek that was
just full of these off-brand kind of other
sci-fi characters.
There was a dude named Rygel who looked like
fat Yoda.
There was a pilot who was just a crab.
I always imagined him as really small but
whenever you see him up close, he's huge.
He's this enormous, and I think they actually
built the puppet.
It was all these puppets, they were all puppets
with weird prosthetics and it's almost exactly
like every other good sci-fi show in that
it took about a season and a half for them
to stop caring enough to turn into something
neat.
Once they got real weird with it, it was great-
Briefly, what's the premise of Farscape for
those who may not have seen it.
I'm so glad that you asked.
Again, I'm not big into geek stuff.
I think I've mentioned that before.
Basically what happens is IASA pilot, IASA
is the International Aeronautics and Space
Association.
Pilot John Crichton is launched into space
on what's called the Farscape project and
accidentally slingshots himself through a
wormhole into another area of the universe.
Happens to the best of us.
Finds himself on board a recently escaped
prison ship, a living ship in Moya.
It's called the Leviathan.
It's this giant living prison ship that's
been taken over by I want to say four of the
prisoners on the ship.
Something like that.
Three or four.
From there hijinks ensues.
Basically Voyager but one guy.
Yeah.
Voyager, smaller cast, smaller budget.
Everybody's covered in paint and goo.
I love it.
So you want to see Farscape come back.
Would you say that you want this to be a reboot?
Would you want this to be a sequel?
What's your dream version of the new 2021
Farscape?
I would love to see a sequel personally.
Again, not into geek stuff, but when the peacekeeper
wars left off the miniseries that they produced
for, I want to say the Hallmark Channel back
in the mid two thousands.
Crichton's son had just been born.
He was presenting into the universe in Lion
King fashion.
This was 17, 18 years ago now.
We've got an adult child who goes out on his
own adventures.
Then we get to bring back the same actors
because most of them doing either voice work
or nothing for the last couple of decades.
I feel like we can get them back pretty easily.
I love that show very much.
It's bonkers and delightful.
If you can watch through it long enough to
get into an episode called Crackers Don't
Matter, it's a good time.
It's weird but I would love to see more of
Nina, what is your pick for a TV show that's
been forgotten that you want to see brought
back?
Okay, I got a weird one and I'm going to sound
like I'm making fun of the show because the
premise is just insane, but I actually loved
the show and I watched every episode when
it was on.
Part of the reason, I'm going to preface this,
part of the reason I want to bring it back
is really selfish is that it ended on like
five cliffhangers because it was very abruptly
canceled.
I still kind of want to know what happened.
It's the year 2003.
If you were a fan of watching things on Fox,
like 24, you might've seen commercials for
a show called Tru Calling.
Tru is spelled T-R-U.
I'm going to send you the poster right now
because it's one of those classic, really
like overexposed mid two thousands TV posters
with a girl staring.
You've got a tiny Jason Priestley in the corner.
You've got a huge Eliza Dushku in the front.
The premise was that Eliza Dushku is a girl
named Tru.
That's her name, Davies.
Was it short for Trudy at least?
They never confirmed that.
Her name was just Tru.
That's fine.
She is, just wait, it gets better.
She is a med student and she starts working
at the morgue and she pulls open a drawer
one day and a corpse looks at her and says
help me.
All of a sudden Tru is transported back to
the day that the woman was murdered and has
to prevent the murder from happening.
Oh dear, so there's time travel involved?
Yes, but it's super specific.
I don't really understand, she never gets
to decide when she's time traveling.
It's just, it's completely-
So it's Pushing Daisies meets Early Edition
meets Quantum Leap.
It's Pushing Daisies if Ned had no autonomy
about what he was doing.
Tru is just constantly set back in time.
Does she have to use a telephone to communicate
with them?
I believe that she gets, it's really hard
to watch the show.
I tried to track down episodes.
They don't exist anymore.
It's hard to find it.
I thought you meant it was difficult to sit
through.
It's very hard to find.
Yeah.
You guys are not going to laugh when you hear
everyone else who was on the show because
there's some famous people on the show.
She works in this lab.
I think the only person who knows about her
power.
Her true calling.
Her true calling is her boss Davis.
You get it now, right?
It turns out that her late mother who I don't
think that you ever see, also had the same
power which kind of folds into the story.
The other reason I want this to be brought
back is I don't think either of you are going
to guess.
A lot of people are on the show.
Lizzy Caplan was in season two.
A.J.
Cook From Criminal Minds played a pretty large
role as Lindsey, Tru's best friend.
Matt Bomer played her boyfriend.
Jason Priestley shows up as a guy who has
the exact same power as Tru, except his name
is not Tru or any permutation of that word.
His name is Untrue.
God this sucks.
Her boss Davis, who also works in the morgue,
is played by none other than a little known
actor you might've heard of named Zach Galifianakis.
I want them to bring this show back for no
other reason than to make Zach Galifianakis
do this show again.
He would make it so much weirder.
You're not wrong.
They're talking to dead, could we call it
between two urns?
Yes, we can.
That's the only way it should come back.
I don't want to Nina because this whole thing
sucks so bad.
Nothing is going to fix this.
Tru Calling but her name is Tru.
It was abruptly canceled in 2005.
Season two was like five episodes, they just
pulled the plug.
The people who loved it, me, probably only
me.
They were like just one girl in Philadelphia
is watching this.
Let's cancel the show.
There's one viewer, she lives in Philadelphia.
Not good enough.
I remember being as a teenager being like,
I need to know what happens.
It's also such a delightfully stupid premise.
Zack Galifianakis, no one was like, oh, the
chubby lab tech is going to be the biggest
star from the show and yet, and yet.
Have you seen the show iZombie?
Yes.
It's a very similar premise done much better.
It's a similar premise done much better.
I guess then that means that you won't accept
my, I was going to say it has been rebooted
as a better show called iZombie, but you're
not into that.
You're like, no, you want Zack Galifianakis
specifically.
No.
Also, she's a zombie which is why she, right?
It's a much better premise.
She has to eat the brain so she eats the brains
of the people.
She is a doctor.
She becomes a zombie.
She has to work in the morgue and she eats
the brains because she's a zombie and she
needs to eat.
When she does that, she finds out that there's
unsolved murders and she goes and solves the
murders.
It's the exact same premise as Tru Calling
without the time travel and for a pretty good
reason.
The other issue with Tru Calling is she goes
back and she stops these people from being,
she doesn't solve the murders, she prevents
murders.
Then she's directly contributing to overpopulation.
A problem plaguing our world.
That is dark from every angle.
She's changing history.
She's literally altering history.
What if we had a Tru Calling spinoff where
it was the ramifications of every murder she
prevented?
What if it's a sequel series and someone's
going back in time to stop her from stopping
the murders.
To remurder the people.
To remurder the people to set the timeline
right.
I love it.
Tom's furious.
I've never hated anything as much as I hate
what you just described for the last five
minutes.
If only it was five minutes.
You're so welcome.
That's my pick.
It's Tru Calling.
It was on Fox.
My pick is also a castoff from Fox but from
even further back in history.
It's a little show starring John Rhys-Davies
and Jerry O'Connell.
Tom knows.
Sliders.
In another universe I do.
The premise of Sliders is that-
Tom's in physical pain.
Quinn Mallory...
You wanted Muppets Star Trek.
I get Sliders.
My pitch was let's put sock puppets on Michael
Dorn and have a great day.
No, I deserve what's happening to me right
now.
I think Tom picked the only show anyone actually
liked.
I liked sliders for a while.
Nobody liked it.
I'm very alone.
People really like Farscape.
The premise of Sliders is that this guy invents
a machine that allows him to slide from one
universe to another.
He and three other people-
A flawless premise.
His professor, a girl he's interested in,
and a random dude who's driving get sucked
into a portal and the machine breaks so that
he can't get home and they have to keep sliding
from universe to universe to hopefully get
back to their universe.
Hoping with each slide that it'll be the slide
that finally takes them home.
Dr. Samuel Beckett.
Absolutely.
There's a Quantum Leap element to it.
The show was not the best show, but it's a
great premise.
So it's different from Tru Calling in that
it was not the best show anyone's ever seen.
Got it.
It was better than Tru Calling.
Impossible.
I'm going to quit this job and burn my computer.
It was better than Tru Calling.
That's not possible.
Jonathan Rhys-Davies, that's his name, right?
I'm getting it right.
I think it's just John.
I'm very tired.
John Rhys-Davies.
The legend from the Lord of the Rings trilogy.
From Indiana Jones and the Raiders of the
Lost Ark.
From so many movies.
He's a great character actor.
He's in this series as Professor Arturo.
He's just chewing the scenery and he's being
a stuffy angry professor guy who's talking
to young Mr. Mallory and trying to get him
to do science better.
It's just the great premise because from one
world to the next, it's basically your built
in Twilight Zone machine.
Every universe there's something weird.
There's some weird thing that's off.
It sounds like a sloppier Doctor Who.
It's not dissimilar from Doctor Who.
It is a sloppier Doctor Who.
It's a little bit more grounded than Doctor
Who.
I think for me, if you went in with a good
budget.
If you went in with knowing what your arc
is and maybe a 10 episode season and you say,
this is how we get from the first episode
to the final episode.
This is the story.
Instead of saying like, gosh, I hope we get
picked up for the next season.
This was also made in an era where networks
were producing 24 episodes a season, right.
It's just not tenable for anything.
It's crazy that people used to do that.
Tighten it up.
Be specific with what you're doing from world
to world to world.
Get a great cast.
Get a good budget.
You've got a really good show that has a premise
that can go on for as long as it needs to
but also doesn't have to go on that long at
all.
I think that could be really fun.
That's my pick.
Now Brian, if you don't mind my asking, would
you please reenact the theme song from Sliders?
Wasn't it like, (scatting) Wasn't it something
like that?
I don't remember.
I honestly don't remember.
I remember the little logo would pop up and
go, Sliders.
That's all I remember.
That's what I was looking for.
I hope our audience is happy to know that
this is the video they can watch if they want
to watch Tom slowly die inside as Brian and
I talk.
I feel like I'm staring into the dark crystal
right now.
What else did you want us to say?
If not Tru Calling-
He just wanted us all to say Farscape and
then go home.
That's what he wants.
I also said Farscape.
I've put my soul out on a chopping board and
then I let you guys cut it up into little
pieces.
Nina, what was the Tru Calling theme song?
It was like somebody save.
It was like one of those Evanescence knockoff
kind of things.
Is the Smallville?
It was indistinguishable.
I looked up the opening credits and I was
like, this sounds like Smallville written
by Evanescence and I turned it off.
Tom, do you remember the Farscape theme song
because I do.
Do you want to hear it?
The Farscape theme song said like your most
obnoxious friends sings Rick and Morty theme
song at karaoke when they're already like
half a bottle of tequila in.
It's just this like wailing way too big.
Do you want to play it ?
No.
Cause I thought it was-
We can't play it.
It was Farscape.
Going to Farscape.
We're on a Farscape out here in space.
Muppets in space.
It was really, really good.
I'm going to go learn an actual trade skill.
I'll see you around.
Love you guys.
Love you too.
Do you guys want to watch Tru Calling?
No.
I just want to die.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe.
So you don't miss a single video.